out of bench point but that's an  important point  for their  scoring star brandon ingram  got the first free throw  out comes graham out comes valenciunis  income clark and temple  willie green with  what appears to be defensive  substitutions  ingram this time makes them both  it's 109 to 98 new orleans pistons had a  15 point third quarter lead frank  jackson down the lane to the rim shot is  swatted by ingram  on the scoop  there's going to be a technical foul on  the pelicans because they just did  something  truly foolish you'll see it  the block shot by england now watch what  he does folks just watch this okay  he gets down in frank jackson's face  like he's gonna help him up but he  actually  screams in his face in front of the  official  a taunting technical  on ingram  [Applause]  frank jackson makes the technical foul  free throw  yeah you'll get an even better look at  it this time watch this  [Applause]  face-to-face  easy call  minute 43 to play it's 109.99  [Music]